should be going live let's see I'll
check always need to check and make sure
that we're actually live
um waiting for me to start now we'll see
when we get some company on the internet
but hopefully we
will achieve that let's see
let me see 13 people
there we are all right well everybody
you are in for a real treat today kind
of an unusual scenario where I have a a
friend in the internet age that I met
from great distance and he uh he's
become a friend we haven't met in person
although we are going to meet in June
when I give a talk at the Royal
Institution I will provide you more
information about that soon and that's
Professor Martin Bauer Martin is the an
assistant professor no you're an
associate professor right how does it
work associate now congratulations in
the department of physics and he has
been working uh this is at Durham yeah
right and it has this uh this moniker
This Acronym in front ukri which I know
means United Kingdom research initiative
research initiative and then flf what
does that stand for
oh that's uh um future leader Fellowship
which funds my research at the moment
that's phenomenal so he is a current
leader in the explication of some of the
most difficult hard to understand but in
his capable mind and brain becomes
transparent even to simple
experimentalists like yours truly uh and
Martin is has an act for that and he's
been doing that on Twitter he's grown
exponentially and today we're talking
because not of a book normally Martin we
have authors that have written books I
hope you'll write a book someday and
will always have you back on the podcast
whenever you're available but he's on to
discuss a very important paper which I
encountered you know 30 years ago as a
beginning graduate student and that's
called the stern Gerlach experiment and
we'll talk about what that experiment
has meant to physics but the reason that
he's on is because of a uh of a chance
maybe Serendipity brought him to this
project and that was uh by chonda
Prescott Weinstein is a professor at the
University of New Hampshire yeah
and she uh made a outrageous claim that
this paper which is so foundational so
fundamental was not available in English
and you know I I only know a couple
words in German uh Martin and one of my
favorites uh is krankovagon
are you familiar with that word
of course yes
which I believe means ambulance uh or
you know cranky kids when I take my kids
to school anyway uh Martin translated
this paper uh it's called actually you
should just read it because I want to
hear your mellifluous German accent so
if you would please indulge us with the
actual German title and German of the
paper that you translated uh you know
spurred on by our uh our colleague
Shonda
in German which is actually not so easy
to translate because
something that doesn't really exist in
that sense and it's not something that
um was has a direct translation into
English so what what people did is uh
calling it space quantization and it
kind of matches what people had in mind
back then when they did the experiment
but it's not actually what they
discovered right I'm sure we get to this
yes and what makes it so uh so important
to physics that would warrant it being
translated only about a hundred years
after its uh actual publication what
what does this experiment mean to uh to
science uh in general but uh
specifically to quantum physics first
what was the immediate impact of this
paper
so that that's two different questions
so looking back what they did is they
discovered the spin of the electron and
um they not only discovered the spin of
the electron they also discovered that
the spin of the electron is quantized so
it can only have discrete values it
cannot have an arbitrary value like a
classical angular momentum
back then what they were out to discover
or what they were out to disprove at
least half of them well to disprove that
is um that thing that they called space
quantization that meaning that there is
also just a discrete number of angular
momentum values but for the atoms for
the whole atom so Bohr had that idea the
Bohr atom model prescribes that the
electrons surround the nucleus on some
orbits right we know now this is not an
exact description but back then it was
helpful to describe the biome series and
this discrete Spectra distribute lines
and that that were discovered and back
then
um there was something like this called
the z-man effect line splitting in the
magnetic field
and people back in the in the 1910s to
1920s when this was discovered tried to
explain it within that model
and it didn't quite make sense and
eminent physicists like boar himself and
summerfeld had the idea that maybe this
angular momentum that basically tells
you the plane in which the electrons
were about to rotate about the nucleus
can only have discrete values we can
only Power into certain directions
so um or said that that might be helpful
in explaining it and someone felt
actually had a paper where he said this
can have three values it can be like
aligned with the magnetic field or a
formula to the magnetic field in two
different directions and then Sterling
Gala set out to test that they said well
if that's the case we can put on an
inhomogeneous magnetic field
um that results in a force on on
anything that has a magnetic moment and
if this is true we should observe a
number of spots where these atoms end up
once they Traverse an homogeneous
magnetic field so that was the actual
experiment they had a little furnace
they had silver atoms and they had with
very very much at the Forefront of the
technology back then they produced a
vacuum funneled them the the server
atoms through a little
um little hole at the furnace then
through this magnetic field and put them
on a little plate to see whether this
discrete Spectrum actually appears or
whether they it's a continuous Spectrum
as you would expect if it was a
classical relaxing moment right so if
you if you imagine you have a magnetic
field and you move
um like a bar magnet through that field
depending on its orientation it will be
deflected up or down and if it has some
angle with the magnetic field it will be
deflected somewhere on the Spectrum and
the quantum theory said that's not going
to happen what's going to happen is you
will only have a discrete number of
spots on the screen because there cannot
be any value of this angular momentum it
has to either line or misalign with a
magnetic field
and Stern who um was the person who who
had the idea for the concept of this
experiment he actually didn't believe in
the Bohr model at all he wanted to
disprove it he had heard of this and he
had thought about it he said well if
that's true we should have seen it
before we have like if you have like a
hydrogen gas for example and you put
light rays into the gas there should be
an effect that you see because the
magnetic fields of within the magnetic
field the the atoms would adapt and the
library would be absorbed and not
absorbed depending on how that looks
like so he was very skeptical in fact it
is a famous quote of him
um that he's he's quoted as saying if
this nonsense of bore proves right in
the end I will create physics he was
really opposed to that idea
which is for that is something that uh
is to be said about physicists in
general you don't need to believe in the
hypothesis that you're testing
um the your motivation might as well be
that you want to rule it out
um so so he was strongly opposed to um
to this model and he actually would have
been very happy to find that it's not
true but my last I found this spectrum
they found two spots
um one up like like a splitting in this
in this line and that proved in the end
that uh there was only a number of
discrete possible values for this
angular momentum they didn't know that
has anything to do with the electron
back then they still thought they had
proved the ball model and actually said
in the postcard to board but
congratulating him
um that he was right in the end but a
couple of years later it was it became
clear what we have now in textbooks that
this experiment showed that the electron
has a spinner a Quantum angular momentum
itself and that which doesn't affect
which doesn't disprove the poor I mean
the Bohr model is wrong let's let's get
that out of the way right it's useful
but it's wrong and I think that has a
lot of parallels to some of the
scientific debates and disputes that you
and I sometimes engage with our
colleagues about uh on Twitter and other
phora and that's that you know something
can be predictive and and actually
correct in a certain level of
approximation But ultimately falsifiable
the atom is not a tiny little planetary
system as we know now but that was
incredibly useful and in fact we can use
it as we can use Newtonian gravity to
get to the moon and the planets we don't
need Einstein for that we can actually
use it for most of the spectroscopy that
that we would do in the lab where there
aren't tiny little effects one thing
I've always wanted to ask you Martin
um and and as a as the token
experimentalist you know who appears on
my channel uh I I can always ask these
questions without fear of reprisal but
but that's um is there such a thing as
an unperturbed atom I mean when I teach
quantum mechanics we start off with the
Schrodinger equation we start off with
this notion that there is a little
planetary system uh like born vision and
then we broaden it out and we add in
actual perturbations and we'll talk
about what is the perturbation that
leads to the stern gerlock effect and
that leads to the splitting and why does
it require an inhomogeneous magnetic not
a homogeneous one but is there such a
thing as an unperturbed you know system
or is it only just sort of a useful a
useful Paradigm in which to do
predictions that for theorists
I mean in a sense it goes to the heart
of quantum mechanics that you can't
really have such a thing
um or put otherwise say for example you
you are a brilliant experimentalist it
works in atomic physics and you isolate
an atom you put it in the Trap and you
Shield it from all the magnetic fields
of the earth and whatever could
potentially have an effect you will for
example never be able to screen gravity
these effects are so small that they'll
never make any effect that is going to
put up the kind of physics that you want
to test with this atom but there are
physical effects that are impossible to
get rid of and more generally is also
the interaction with the detector itself
now if you want to measure an effect in
a quantum mechanical system you have to
actually interact with the system itself
we have to interact with the atom in
that case right so that will perturb it
as well so I um but coming back to your
point about theories I don't think there
is I'm not sure there is such a thing as
a perfect all-explaining Theory I think
one lesson of physics of the last 100
years at least is that whenever we find
a new layer it is just that it is
another layer of reality it is it is
precise up to a certain
energy which we can test it and then we
can't really say whether it is exact or
not and more often than not theories get
replaced by something more precise which
doesn't make them wrong and at all it
just tells you that the realm of of
Applied applicability of that theory is
not infinite you can't go to infinitely
short distances or infinitely High
energies and use even generativity will
break down eventually so um and it's not
clear to me that there's any theory that
has this property at least in the
Paradigm of effective field theories
this is one of the lessons we have
learned that basically you'll go from
Shell to Shell and learn a little bit
more a little bit more and the theory is
a little bit more precise but they can
always think of situations where it's
going to eventually break down
so I'm showing the paper uh the the
archive reference that I'm going to put
that in the show notes down below as
well so you start off with the Preamble
about the motivation for this the actual
reference so the paper is over 100 years
old it published in 1922 uh with the
title that you gave it it's actually
gerlock and Stern which I didn't know
that but at any rate
um we know it as a Stern gerlock so it
talks about the space quantization so
let's let's be clear when you talk about
when we talk about space quantization
these scientists are not talking about
uh something general relativistically
they're not talking about quantization
of you know at the plank length or
something like that I'm not saying space
is quantized correct what are they
saying no
yeah it's an unfortunate name it is the
name that was given to um to the um and
the literal translation would probably
better be directional quantization
that's more close to the German word I
just kept in line with what people used
back then that wrote English literature
so when I when we did the translation I
should also mention Philip heldick he's
a cosmologist who um helped me quite a
bit with translating the paper
um being a native English speaker so we
we did this together
um it's a longer story why he is not the
archive version he will be on the
journal version though
and um the the
um what is meant by this is that there
is a directional effect in quantization
so that basically the angular momentum
is quantized leading to this effect it's
something that was implicitly clear
before like there was indirect
um proof of that even though people
weren't actually convinced that this
effect would be there it's the first
direct
proof of that this existed it is a
really um it is a pioneering experiment
if you think about it that's the first
vacuum to that degree it is the first
molecular beam that they had to that
degree when that experiment was built
Bohr himself said that he didn't believe
it might work so um there's another
famous quote
um that I'd double checked just for this
podcast it's uh Kerala who answered uh
answer to war that no experiment is so
dumb that it shouldn't be tried when he
was when he was mentioning that he was
unsure whether it might work
um so so that it is really really
difficult experiment back then and it
took them away to get it to work but
eventually it worked out and with
regards to the space quantization the
the effect is different from all that
had been seen before because all
quantization effects that you had before
like the Obama series for example they
showed that there is a quantization if
you excite an atom so an excited atom
will show you these lines or an excited
atom and the magnetic field has should
so it can can give rise to the Zeeman
effect but this experiment showed that
the ground state of an atom there was no
excitement at all it still has this
quantization property still confirmed
quantum mechanics and that is why it has
this had this fundamental impact
um back then so I'm showing figure one
from the paper which uh demonstrates the
source and the beam yeah that's true I
didn't realize uh that I was the first
kind of molecular beam experiment which
would later lead to things like nuclear
magnetic resonance and the work of
Robbie and and other you know tremendous
uh contributions to our knowledge uh and
as well as you know really making an
impact it's rather than an experiment
has an impact both experimentally
technologically and also philosophically
and I think the the strange thing is
about this is that it really highlights
that the notion of spin doesn't it
Martin so
um what do we mean by spin what how do
you think about spin there's a book by
tamanga called what is spin I read it uh
didn't really Come Away with a much
better uh appreciation of how to
visualize it is it impossible to
visualize because where these
macroscopic creatures how do you
visualize as a as one of the most
respected theorists of your generation
how how do you visualize in a working
sense what is spinning what does it mean
and just restrict ourselves to the
electron for now
so when I try to visualize it I can't do
better than you or anyone else I think
you just think in terms of what we know
from microscopic well so when I think in
my mind about a spinning electron I
literally think of that it is like a
little
um a little Point like sphere and a tiny
sphere that spins around this axis that
is not actually what's going on as we
know from from the mathematical
description but it interacts with
everything around it as if this were
true so the spin of an electron combines
with angular momentum as macroscopic
angular momentum wood with the only
difference that it is quantized but
that's also true for angular momentum
itself like every every system that has
angular momentum also has quantized
angular momentum just have to probe it
carefully enough and once you have
enough
spinning or rotating objects then you
get this macroscopic situation where you
actually don't see the quantization
property but what concerns the the my
imagination I don't think I can do
better than anyone else on that God it
is fundamentally different though
because it is in a way it is closer to
Mars than to angular momentum because
spin is a is um is a fundamental
property that is independent of the
inertial frame in which you look at it
so whether you look at a system spinning
or someone move into the system spinning
the spin of an object is invariant it's
a consequence of the fundamental
symmetry group of space time so it is a
there's a quantum number that is not
related to some internal symmetry that
electric charge for example it is
related to the same symmetry that gives
rise to boosts and to um two masses the
other fundamental quantity that is
invariant between inertial frames so um
that is I think a bit of a deeper
Insight that you get if you look at the
fundamental theory that gives rise to
spin but if I try to imagine what the
spinning electron is I don't think there
is a way to improve or haven't seen yet
a better display
so I'm showing on the screen now that a
figure two and three which show the
behavior of the um of the impact on an
Emulsion so talk about these two
different diagrams I always thought the
the one on the right which is
the scale the rulers inverted or it's
flipped left to right and upside down
but it always looked kind of like
somebody's mouth like you know with a
little thing underneath the nose what is
this uh depicting and why why is this
uh so so indicative of the fact that
these have spins and not some other
Quantum phenomenon
so in the in the left picture what you
see is what you would expect classically
you have a line and the line would
broaden if you funnel different
um atoms with different aligned angular
momentum for the magnetic field because
the angular momentum would in this
picture spread from left to right on the
right hand side is what they actually
observed with where the magnetic field
turned on
um so so if the if the classical Theory
would have been right then you would
have seen the left picture which is
taken without the magnetic field and
once you turn it on the line would have
drawn would have spread out a little bit
but what happened instead is the line
split into two lines and that is exactly
the effect that the quantum theory
predicted in fact there were two
competing so I mentioned before
Summerfield at the time was convinced
that there would be three lines there
would be a line for
um
perpendicular to the magnetic field and
a line aligned and anti-aligned with a
magnetic field so here was he was
thinking there might be three lines
showing up but Bohr had some argument
that the central line is unstable and
should be only two these these
predictions back then I should add are
not what takes place here in the end in
the end it is the spin of the electron
that has only two possible values that
spreads the line but um this is what
happens the the electron can only
project to two possible spin values spin
up or spin down with respect to the
magnetic field and so it ends up either
on the left or on the right of this
picture now why do we get it why do we
get the the closure of the lips on the
you know on the sides rather why don't
we just get two parallel lines Martin
if there's two spins oh I think because
the the magnetic field is not it's an
inhomogeneous magnetic field that is not
perfect but I I'm I'm not an
experimentalist so I can't give you the
details about that I think that that the
electrons that were not funneled
centrally for that field we're not um
feeding the its full effect so they
weren't really deflected as much and I
believe it's true if the apparatus was
physically larger the separation would
be greater another it's sort of the
product of the length Traverse times the
inhum now it has to be an in-home
ingenious magnetic field why don't we
explain why that is the case why can't
it just be two refrigerator magnets uh
you know creating a North and the South
Pole why does it have to be this strange
inhomogeneous magnetic field uh shown
generated by this odd looking pole type
Behavior
so if you had an homogeneous magnetic
field meaning a field where the field
lines are all parallel for example and
that magnetic field the spins might
still project to that field lines so
there's a Magnetic Moment the spin of
the atom has uh results in a magnetic
moment because it is um
because it feels the magnetic field and
then it might still project to these
lines it will still align the atoms but
there is no force in a homogeneous
magnetic field that would actually make
them split to the left and to the right
so they might they might still travel
through it but they will not be split
that is why it was necessary of this
inhomogeneous magnetic field I want to
re-emphasize and that is actually the
accomplishment of Gala out of the two he
actually made this experiment with the
one that told Bohr that they should try
it even if the things is impossible
basically
um he he made it work so stairs don't
have the idea and he um wrote the paper
previously where he uh that is
translated into English usually look
it's also on three pages or something
where he's very unhappy about Bros
portfolio and he says I'm going to prove
that Warren basically we have to build
this experiment but only when Gala
arrived in Frankfurt he made it work so
um it is technically a really really
difficult back then it is an incredible
experiment that they made work and that
that inner genius magnetic field is part
of what made it hard
and why did they have to use silver why
did they choose to use silver and not
some other atom
so um silver well we know now that
silver has a single electron that is
responsible um for its spin I don't
think they wanted aware of that back
then I don't think this is the
motivation of why they use serve in the
first place they could have used other
items as well I think there is um
there's an experimental consideration
there that you have to have it available
you have to be able to
turn it into a um into a gas you have to
be able to handle it safely so I think
these were the considerations but I
might be wrong I don't know exactly what
the what motivated them to use server
specifically it could be because there
was the reason we need two lines or say
that again that it's silver it results
in two lines yeah
um so I think part of the reason might
have been that you know photographic
emulsions were using silver and you know
halides and stuff like that so it's
probably convenient to use silver for
the exposure perhaps that was one of the
reasons
um now this experiment then takes on
kind of a life of its own right so they
they go on to get some some great Fame
and I love I love to read
acknowledgments first of all I love a
short paper I mean as much as anybody
this would have been fun to do
um I I like to uh to look at the um the
foundation let's see it says the
electromagnet necessary with funds from
the foundation of the Kaiser Wilhelm
Institute to the director Mr a Einstein
is that first name Albert
yes of course it is so so stern was
Albert Einstein's first assistant long
before he moved to Zurich he knew him
very well and he moved with him to
search and then when Einstein went to
Berlin Stern moved to Frankfurt where he
started working with Gala and um this
was just after the war so money was
really hard to get by and there was
actually heavy inflation setting on much
worse than today even though we like to
complain but there was a different time
so they didn't have the funds for this
experiment really and to keep it going
they had to write letters they had to
ask for funding and Einstein was asked
in a letter for 8 000 ICE Mark and he
gave them ten thousand so he was really
in support of this experiment
um Wednesday he gave obviously he
supported them in getting it it was not
his money but as a director in Berlin he
was able to make that work and that's
not the only money they received they
bore wrote letters for them too
um after you saw that Gala somehow was
in a position to make that work and I
don't know how this worked precisely but
I think he he knew someone in New York
and Goldman from Goldman Sachs Fame
he he had family in Frankfurt and he
funded this experiment as well with
several hundred dollars which was a lot
back then wow so um they they navigated
that with a lot of external money that
they had to bring in not unlike today
when we do our experiments so often
that's right people think oh well back
then back then they had this cheap
little experiments that were easy for
them to build and it was just a matter
of a few hundred bucks or whatever to
make that work but it was a terrible
um terribly hard to get the funding for
these experiments as well that hasn't
changed as much even though the digits
might have changed and this was a a busy
time for Einstein because you know when
they're doing the experiment that was uh
that was around the time he had well he
won the 1921 about prize but it wasn't
given to him until the following year
for reasons I don't quite understand
maybe you do but
um but this is a quite a busy time and I
like that they're you know really
cooperating with the uh with the with
teams at different institutions and it's
and it's quite uh of course in service
of of the truth which is this which is
this you know kind of bizarre notion
that the electron may have this you know
not only hidden but philosophically
almost troubling type of behavior and
what's what's kind of delightful to me
is that later on these types of
phenomena the spin of the electron and
other things would go on to make
Einstein rather nervous about the
underpinnings of quantum mechanics so
maybe talk about the influence of this
paper and the notion of spin being a
really honest to goodness intrinsic
property of the electron or any Quantum
system
what did this do uh for for philosophy
in particular to Einstein perhaps
so um well there was there was there's a
lot that happened following up the
experiment there was an immediate impact
Einstein and Ian Fest wrote a paper
within weeks
um on this particular experiment
um so it was clear that they showed
something that um was such a uh such an
important proof of quantum mechanics
that the theory wasn't worked out back
then what I should say so this was in a
time where um as as we mentioned the
Bohr model was basically what people
went off on so they they didn't have the
full quantum mechanics that were still
in its uh very early years so they they
didn't have that they just showed
basically that the current best theory
of nature
um classical mechanics up to that point
apart from the early signs of quantum
mechanics didn't quite work again so the
um and they showed that this is the case
if you have ground state
attends as well not just some excited
States or photoelectric effect or
something like this it really was a
fundamental property of Nature and
um Einstein Airfest wrote this paper
basically double checking this they
wrote a paper where they checked whether
there could be any way the classical
effect might lead to this picture it was
uh people really so Stern who was
opposed to the Bohr model and um in
general had a big problem with uh with
these quantum mechanical effects so he
didn't expect it at all he he didn't
believe it still for for a long time he
he struggled
um with the notion that this might be
fundamental and Einstein Airfest wrote a
paper and I think one of the points they
made is that there are some classical
effects so there's a Lambo frequency
there is a way that you might imagine
they can somehow align in an atomic
field and they try to build a model that
this works and understand found it would
take 100 years for this classical effect
to make this final picture also it was a
was a time of great confusion where um
with this experiment just basically put
a nail in the coffin of of classical
mechanics was clear there is no way this
could be described by anything else as
by a new Theory there was some
that was about to appear and um yeah
eventually
um the the
um the fear was worked out by Eisenberg
and schroeding iron later on I was was a
lot of work um going into this Stern
actually
um well yeah I don't know whether you
want to go there right now but um
because you mentioned the Nobel Prize
Einstein proposed a Nobel prize for the
two I think the year after this
experiment as well so he was really um
in favor of that it took much longer for
stern to get it he got it in 44 I think
mengalov never got it
um
that that goes because so so stern was
uh was a Jew he had to leave Germany 10
years later I think he went to
Pittsburgh after that
um and uh just after he made another
important Discovery he measured later
that the neutron the proton have an
anomalous Magnetic Moment meaning they
are not fundamental so looking back this
discovery by him and others was uh
probably as important almost as the
strangola experiment and galat was uh um
he was not a fan of the Nazis he never
joined their party but uh he eventually
was involved with the German version of
the Manhattan Project so he was working
on an atomic board I don't really I'm
not an historian I should
basically put this that never stops
business commenting on History yeah yeah
so so he's uh so he was involved with
that and that's uh part of the reason
why when in 43 or 44 the Nobel Prize
went to start it probably did when it go
to stern only he was proposed many many
times for the for the Nobel Prize
um but girl or later on I should say was
also very much involved in um
anti-nuclear movement in Germany so he
he didn't like the consequence as many
physicists did later on so he did not
receive a price on that that price for
his work right
eventually so but you want to go to
something else other thing you want to
go to the implications of quantum
mechanics yes especially the the I'll
say it say it in German please that say
spooky action at a distance even though
Sabina will correct us both that
Einstein never said that or he didn't
mean that or we don't know because we're
idiots
um Martin what what did it first say it
I can't resist to have maybe like me
having Falcon Falco on and not asking
him to sing Rock Me Amadeus or whatever
anyway how do you say it and what does
it mean
vehicle
um it's spooky spooky action this is
actually a pretty good translation of
that I would say
um and what is meant by this is that in
in quantum mechanics you have two
different aspects you have the um time
well the wave function describes an
object basically before you measure it
and you have the measurement process and
that process going from the description
of the evolution of the wave function to
the actual measurement
is not well described within quantum
mechanics there is no real recipe for
what happens there so people call it the
collapse of the wave function
um uh there there are several
interpretations of this but it is a
non-local effect that Einstein baptized
as a spooky action at a distance and it
becomes most
obvious when you think about entangled
systems entangled systems by which you
can take a wave function that not
describes the single party but it
describes more than one particle that
then obviously you can take um apart you
can move them in different rooms for
example and perform a measurement on one
object that gives you information
immediately about the other object which
then within quantum mechanics it's
completely rational to expect that
because they're described by a single
wave function but for us looks very
spooky so um
Einstein didn't mean specifically that
he made a more General argument that
this non-locality is spooky to him
there's a spooky actions at a distance
but it is often mentioned in the context
of entangled States and when we talk
nowadays about the stern girl lock
experiment it's um it's often you know
kind of presented as a way to not
measure properties of quantum systems
but to prepare Quantum systems so can
you speak about some of the strange
things that happen when you have a
series of black boxes you know filled
with Stern gerlock apparati you can do
all sorts of things you can prepare
things and spin up States and then and
then send them through a another Stern
Gerlach experiment so the output of this
will be two beams right one will be spin
up one will be spin down the two
different lips of the of the pattern
that I showed earlier and then you can
kind of block one of the lips off or one
of the the beams out and then you're
left with a pure spin up or spin down
just depending on your coordinate system
uh beam and then you could put that
through subsequent Sterling gerlock
experiments at different angles and then
all sorts of strange things happen you
want to describe some of the phenomena
that you can obtain with these SG
experiments
yeah so what you um what you would think
is that when you've prepared a beam in a
certain State and and I should mention
that um when I said that these were the
first real molecular beams they had
molecular beams before it's the first
polarized um beam of uh of atoms right
so yeah they they played around with
this quite a couple of years before they
did the actual stone God like experiment
but you would think if you have prepared
a state in a certain
um situation like for example it's been
up in Australian dollar experiment that
would be in that spin state but if you
now have a subsequence jungle so you
have one inhomogeneous field say that
has the um which is aligned up down and
you have won the disaligned left right
and now you filter out the um the S up
component for example and you funnel to
another to the second experiment it will
split again you will see the split now
in the in the other direction so there's
uh this kind of experiments were
actually also directly proposed by
Einstein to make sure that this is um
this is what we really see there's
really quantum mechanics so they they um
he immediately started writing letters
and said let's do two let's do three so
he was he was very much involved with
the development of uh of uh um the
cross-checks of the theory and it's good
to do that because you know this is
something that could have been wrong the
notion of spin could have been falsified
uh or could have been that we truly have
a classical Universe I think that would
have made other problems come about but
it's always sort of reminded me of of uh
Newton's uh experiments with prisms and
color theory and so forth so you know
when you send a beam of white light
through a prism uh it'll separate out
famously into a rainbow uh like spectrum
and uh Newton realized that you could
actually experimentally block you know
say the the green color of a of a beam
that was coming out of this prism say
and then combine it in another prism and
you wouldn't get white light out and so
he realized that it was kind of
synthesis and there was this Duality
associated with it
um I wonder if there are experiments in
your mind nowadays what is sort of the
um the the analog of these types of
measurements we we hear so much about
new forces new fields and so forth
really being manifest is there anything
in your mind as a theorist that is as
exciting or potentially as revolutionary
both the physics and to philosophy
teleology Etc as the stern gerlock
experiment
so the things we don't know right we
don't um we don't know we have no clear
prescription of what experiment
precisely we'll bring this about
um that we are in a slightly different
situation back then we we don't um look
for a theory we have a theory in
fundamental physics at least and we have
one in cosmology as well
um they're both don't like each other
um Einstein's general relativity and the
standard model of particle physics and
we have some ideas how to combine them
but the fundamental problem with testing
these theories like string theory for
example has nothing to do with string
theory directly it has only to do with
the fact that gravity is so insanely
weak that it's completely
um incredible the the to believe that we
can build machines that can test the
energies that will be necessary to see
for example a Quantum effect in in
gravity
so um that is the problem with that but
um there's that's not a reason to not
test whether something is out there and
the most successful version of that for
example is um what we've seen through um
rotational waves in the last couple of
years
um so if you want to me to give an
example right now I would think what is
exciting
um our Atomic interference experiments
for example if you ask exciting and
related to stern galach so Atomic waves
can interfere in the same way as the
interferometer of lasers work in in ligo
for example and you can split at home
equation you can recombine them and the
interference shows you what forever
interacted on the way with the atoms and
these experiments have become incredibly
incredibly precise in the last couple of
years and not only that people have
figured out in the in the US there's an
experiment at firm lab matches that
tries to achieve this in UK with ion
there's an experiment in France as well
they have achieved the separation of
these States before interference over
very large distances so you can move it
you can split the atomic wave like you
can split the laser beam you can move
them far apart and then you can
recombine them and look at the
interference pattern and these are so
incredibly precise these machines that
eventually they will be able to pick up
gravitational waves themselves and they
will test a completely different
Spectrum than the gravitational waves
that it has the ligo Eliza or any other
experiment can test which will be almost
like a like a telescope with your
telescope of rotational waves and a on a
different line with and we should do all
these experiments they are not they are
complementary to each other they they um
achieve an
um an unheard sensitivity
um in their um in their particular range
of wavelength and we don't know what
they will discover but there will be
surprises so like already finds that
there are black hole mergers where we
don't really thought they were and they
tell us something about how black holes
are distributed that has consequences
that will teach us about the theory that
is responsible for the distribution of
black holes which are formed in the um
in the during the history of the
universe so who knows what we will
discover there so these These are
extremely exciting and the particle
physics front as well so whatever the
neck collider is going to be it will
have the main goal to to learn about the
Higgs boson which you just discovered
it's just so by the time student girl
have made their experiment work the
Bible series was known for much longer
than we know about the Higgs boson it
probably is not going to be true once we
have a new collider to test it given
that it takes a long time to build these
things today and we'll probably need
more money than Einstein was happy to
give certain color for that too but we
really should make that we really should
make that point clear we have only seen
that the Higgs boson is there we have
measured its most immediate properties
we know it's Mass we know it's charge we
know it's been but the Higgs particle is
is only the harbinger of a mechanism
that gives Mass to all particles that is
predicted by the standard model and the
only way to really understand whether
this is true in nature is to measure the
potential of the Higgs boson to figure
out whether it's actually the party
that's responsible for that as described
by the Sunday model or whether it's
different
and because it is the only spin zero
particle it has a unique theoretical
possibilities to interact with other
particles we haven't seen yet so there's
something called the Higgs portal which
um only is only possible for spin zero
boson we only have ever seen one of them
which is the Higgs so we really want to
test these things as well as we can and
see what they will um they will tell us
we're going to take questions from the
audience just a reminder anybody who
subscribes to my Twitter or YouTube
account should certainly follow Martin
I've linked his his Twitter account in
the uh in the show notes so if I didn't
I will and uh reminder that I do take
questions on Twitter and on Instagram
and on YouTube where we have recently
surpassed a hundred thousand followers
and I want to thank everybody out there
and all my guests and Martin's my first
you know new guest in the in the new era
of a hundred thousand or more coming up
on 102. yeah so we have great guests
coming up on the podcast if I can get
the budget from YouTube you know maybe
they'll give me some some budget to get
a non-autofocusing camera but we have
Mark kaminkowski uh who I'm sure Martin
knows very well uh he's a guest coming
up uh this weekend
on the podcast we talk about tensions in
cosmology and uh and and so the kind of
way forward that I always like to do is
to get questions from the audience
because my guests are on unequivocally
well suited to answering questions and
so there are a bunch of questions you
know kind of percolating but I'm going
to take the opportunity to just hearken
back to what you just said about the
Higgs boson as the only spin zero
particle known to physics or cosmology
does that give you more confidence in
the existence of inflation in the
Multiverse perhaps or should does it
have any real impact on the on the
physics of the extremely early universe
so I'm not a cosmologist
yeah if you were you know right to
speculate would you would you say it
gives you more Credence in the theory of
inflation or does it not have a bearing
it can't give less right I mean but
could it give you could it give you more
hope that inflation is actually a
correct description of the extremely
early universe
um I don't think it does give you direct
a direct link I think there are models
that um where the Hicks itself is the
influence one so whether the Hicks might
be self-responsible for inflation or
linked to that mechanism but they are
there are some models in a in a
landscape of models that could be
responsible for that and I don't see why
they are particularly motivated I think
they have their problems you would
really need to ask for small just for
that
um my opinion the Multiverse is that is
basically
um the Multiverse is a consequences
can't be tested if cosmology is right if
certain class of course more of
inflation models is true
um the one that seems to be favored by
the data at the moment then the
Multiverse is a is a prediction of these
models but nothing we can directly test
and I think this really
um has has
people fantasizing about this and
um calling physics is crazy for coming
up with a theory like this but it should
be emphasized that all theories that we
have have untestable consequences
they're not directly accessible to us
like Newton's gravitational Theory tells
us that there is going to be a stone and
if you drop it on a planet and Andromeda
is going to fall down but there's no way
for us to go there and check we we can't
really take an apple there and repeat
his experiment on Earth even though we
definitely assume that it is true as
well and the Multiverse is similar it's
not something we can test it is not
scientific in that sense but it is a
consequence of a theory that can be
tested otherwise and we should perform
these tests and the fact that we know
that these kind of theories predict
something like the Multiverse so it
should get people into the business of
thinking about whether it can be tested
if it can never be tested it's not
something we could waste our time with
if someone has a brilliant idea of how
maybe there is a test that nobody has
thought of yet then we should take into
account because that could tell us
whether these theories are right or not
very good okay first question for Martin
comes from a person by the name of cool
cat although he has an ape as his Avatar
she has an ape as her Avatar Brian
Martin is spin a matter of observational
orientation that is could you look at a
span an up particle and it becomes a de
facto spin down
adding and not a physicist but
enthusiastic amateur hungry for more
insight so is it just a matter of like
turn your head and not become spin down
or is there something intrinsically
different about a spin-up for spin down
particle
so what you call has been up and spin
down it actually depends on the way you
look at it you can Define your access
and you can Define the spin with respect
to that the important bit is that you
have these two different orientations
for an electron so um if you once you
measure an electron but you can use a
magnetic field for example then what you
call up and down you will do with
respect to that magnetic field
but that's the that's the underlying
principle so spin up and spin down are
two distinct properties but what whether
if you don't decide to do the experiment
and call it's been up spin down and I
call has been downspin up it's going to
have the same physics in the end
all right cool cat is now subscribed to
your Twitter following uh Mass judge
join the join the crowd
um so another person Gibson LP says uh
chat GPT will render you uh uh basically
uh unnecessary and Superfluous Martin
how do you feel about that uh is chat
GPT or success or call it call it chat
GPT or uh what is it called now chatgpt
or gpt4 right now they just released
this week uh imagine GPT 40 is there
going to be an artificial Bower uh or is
your job security safe at least for net
yeah so for now it definitely is I try
to ask a church GTP some questions that
it gets many of them wrong but I
definitely believe that it's going to
get better and I think it will have its
place in helping to understand and
develop theories I know that uh Martin
Ruiz has this um this idea that
artificial intelligence will just run
away and will have no way in uh in
catching up but I'm not concerned at the
moment I would need to see something way
more impressive even though I think GTP
is very impressive I use it if I need to
write a very boring text for a ground
application I let jet GTP improve my
English and fill in some words I can't
come up with to make it sound a little
bit better but in terms of like
developing new physics it's not very
helpful and even if it could it would
definitely not be able to replace the
experimentalists which are the which do
the real physics right so if you have an
artificial intelligence that builds us a
new collider you can get back to me
happy to to retire then if you can uh if
you can write a little letter like
Einstein did to my funding agencies here
in the US I'd appreciate it
um well one thing you could use it for
you know is kind of uh you're you know
generating tweet ideas and you have this
prolific ability to connect very
abstract very Advanced you know concepts
for millions of people to see I'm just
this weekend you had one about general
relativity in two dimensions and what I
love about you and what you do is you
never dumb it down you never make it
like super simple you include all the
notation and I think that's inspiring
Martin because people see that and it it
may you know induce a young you know
Martin or Brian Keating uh to to go out
and become interested in uh in the game
that is particle physics and
experimental cosmology and theoretical
physics and theoretical cosmology
um so I want to talk about uh some of
the what I call the academic media hype
in complex which is kind of like the
military industrial complex which is we
we have these you know discoveries and
they'll be oh there's new physics found
and and just yesterday or two days ago
you
resulted at something you know I talked
about something that could have been a
departure from the standard model how
serious should people lay audience
people that may be listening and
wondering how seriously should they take
it when they hear a physicist what
should they do give us a rubric when you
hear new force of nature discovered or
you know cosmologist you know the Big
Bang is a violent disagreement with
these observations what should a
layperson do when they hear such a claim
so so
um what I would say is that um so the
first thing that everyone should do is
read beyond the headline if you ever
have written an article I've contributed
something you will know that the
headlines of these articles are not even
set by the people that write the
Articles themselves they're set by the
um journal and they are said such that
they attract as many clicks as possible
they're not said to have the most
realistic
representation of whatever is described
by the physics has been discovered and
then I would pay attention to the
general so when you read something in a
journal online say for example then pay
attention to what else do they write if
every other article they write tells you
the standard model is broken and the Big
Bang is wrong and there has been a
wormholdenship and what else right if
every article sounds like that or every
article tells you that physics is is
finished and we have found the solution
to everything or not right if it's a if
it's a extreme hyped um kind of a sense
message that you get from the general
articles there then don't don't read
these kind of journals if you find a
more balanced view then you're at the
right place and I think to my surprise
kind of because I didn't plan that
really I um I didn't start that that way
when I started twittering about these
things
um the people that read it were quite
interested and I kept going but I didn't
anticipate that so many people would
stay interested in these kind of
technical topics from time to time to my
surprise if you if you find the right
people on Twitter this is a really good
place to get comments on these articles
so so people that are on Twitter are
more likely in my opinion if they are
experts on a topic to tell you whether
something you read is wrong or whether
it is just completely hyped up for no
reason so this is also good to just get
a second and a third opinion if you
think you found something that sounds
believable to you but maybe quite a
little bit too good a little bit too
negative they're good to be true okay uh
RuPaul uh
do you think that we should get funding
to you train large language models on
physics conversations classes
derivations to solve specific problems
not just write proposals
should it should it be a should be a
topic that can be funded in other words
not not just I definitely think it
should let me just say my Ben because I
love to talk uh well I love to talk
about myself Martin if you haven't
noticed um on my favorite subject but uh
but in all seriousness uh I do think it
has a utility for
um uh for discovering new ways of
pedagogical impact for example we could
take I I translated I didn't translate I
took I was granted the permission from
the publisher which is the University of
California to take Galileo's dialogue
and convert it to an audiobook and it is
the first audiobook ever made by Galileo
and we had people like Frank wilcheck
and Carlo ravelli and Jim Gates and
Fabiola giannati and my friend Lucio
pichirillo and we recorded it and I was
thinking it's about a million words and
Galileo's amazing writer why don't I
just dump it into some chat bot and and
then I can go away and we can teach you
know you know freshman mechanics uh like
from Galileo not for Brian Keating even
though I think I'm a great teacher I
can't compare with the Maestro so I
definitely I'm just assuming we're going
to use it for teaching and improving the
pedagogical method that you and I employ
which is no different than what Galileo
did 400 years ago and it's even no
different than what they did in the
University of Bologna in the year 1089
when the first University came about
some guy uh or gal scratching with a
piece of rock on another piece of rock
and and their substudents in the
audience except back then Martin the
students could go on strike if so if
they didn't like us they would go on
strike we wouldn't get paid so uh so
thankfully that barbaric you know
inhumane process has has gone away but I
guarantee it's going to be now I don't
I'm not a sanguine that could be used to
discover new laws of physics and I
always use this example but you know
stop me if you disagree but you know do
you know what Einstein called his
happiest thought Martin
his happiest thought no I don't know
that he said that an observer in free
fall would experience no gravitational
feel
so I always ask the question how could
you train a computer to a a visualized
Free Fall you know do a gedonkan
experiment you know a visualize Free
Fall A and B how could you connote what
it means to feel happy and it seems to
me that that was the most important
thing to Einstein he talked about
something deeply hidden in magnetic
fields and quantum mechanics spooky
action at a distance these are all very
human-centric visceral Sensations so
maybe to expand upon RuPaul do you think
that Beyond just taking conversations in
language that an artificial intelligence
could actually come up and create
creatively
a new Theory of physics
um I so I think
um these these models and artificial in
general intelligence in general and
again I should appreciate that we're
saying I'm not an expert in the topic
that never prevents me from saying
anything
I fully expect that uh that I will have
a huge impact on all research Fields
right we already see people that are um
for example let them feed in a whole
Medical Library and ask them for drugs
that haven't been discovered and they
just scramble together something that
might might have an application right so
they they will have a huge impact I'd
like to compare them with say um uh
computers in general before computers
were around or calculated in the first
place when the theoretical physics want
to work out a new model which is sit
down and any every single calculation
had to be done by pen and paper and you
had to look up values of logarithms in
books that had been written by Russians
a couple of decades ago or something
right and then you have to double check
some integral values and it was a really
really difficult slow process and
computers have revolutionized that using
computer programs I can now write a
program myself that has gives you a
simulation for something I can
immediately get this inside with on my
fingertips right it's an incredible
Revolution and I will be similar it will
be very similar to that I think it will
uh will be a new tool that will improve
the way we approach these problems
enormously but one thing
um won't go away I think it will only be
re-emphasized by the Advent of AIA and
that is that what what makes a real
scientist a great scientist is to figure
out the right question to ask
so um this this is already the case
right everyone who does research knows
that you can work um on a third topic
forever and then when you finish the
research project you figure out oh well
if I had faced it that way it would have
been clear to me what is going on I
could have solved this problem much
faster right right so this is this has
been true forever back when Einstein
figured out special relativity with all
the dining experiments that you were
talking about with the with the train
and the when the elevator and whatever
he was thinking of to to make this
analogies and to figure out what how the
Dynamics really work and why general
relativity is basically impossible to
avoid if if special relativity is true
um if he had asked for example
um an II give me a theory that respects
Lauren symmetry which was already
realized in Maxwell's equations if you
if you give me a theory of mechanics
that respects that and I doubt jet GTP
would be able to do it without knowing
it already but a future I might be able
to do it right but to find that question
question to to narrow it down to that
question that can be answered that way
that is really the achievement of a of a
great scientist and still also I should
remark um more more and more that this
is only true for the theoretical
considerations
I don't see AI replacing
experimentalists they might improve some
methods but as it is now they don't see
them building the next best experiment
all right let's talk about experiment
then
um what will be this is from Omni Jesus
which I consider for naming one of my
kids actually Martin I don't know if you
knew that Omni but Jesus asks what will
we test at CERN in the coming years
and then how can we draw a line between
the beginning and end of it all and what
will be around this line uh and then the
tree of okay forget that let me just ask
this first question
um he should have stopped that one or
she should have stopped that one Omni
but Jesus come on uh what's uh most
exciting that's coming up that will be
tested at CERN in the next coming years
from your perspective
so there's a bunch of things someone
will um start the program of of or
continue the program of figuring out
what the hex really is it will improve
measuring the couplings of the Higgs um
with the discovery of the Higgs bolon we
have so far only tested a handful of its
interactions with the other Quantum
parties that we know of and we want to
see as many as we can because every
single one of them is predicted by the
standard model and if even one of them
is wrong we know there's something else
out there but there is only one aspect
of CERN so um the Large Hadron Collider
is a Hadron Collider so it collides
proton with protons and you build such a
machine when you don't know what you
look for if you already know what you
want to test you don't do this because
it's really really messy you have a lot
of backgrounds it's really really really
hard to um uh to to get predictions
tested at the Heartland collider you
could Collide electrons or maybe you
could light muons in the future and
there would be a much much cleaner
experiment but um the big advantages
then that even though you might look for
some things particular you have the
potential to see anything and the new
phase of the LHC the third run of the
LHC will have an enormous statistics
it's billions of billions of collisions
so that means even if you have tiny tiny
effects you can tickle them out of the
data and that is of course important for
the exposure because it is really
difficult to produce a Higgs boson but
more importantly or equally importantly
I'd say there's also mesons in the
standard model like B mesons they make
from bottom walks or chaos for example
that have extremely rare decays they are
so rare that Within These billions and
billions of collisions that you have and
you produce billions of these mesons you
only have a handful of these decays and
some of them we haven't ever seen and we
will only now be able to see them and
these tests are really important they
are basically over constraining what the
standard model tells us so every one of
these tests could show us something that
we didn't expect
and it might be counter-intuitive but
the tests of these light particles that
we perform at the Large Hadron Collider
we all physicists together basically
um they they are sensitive to um
extremely high energy scales
um and this is a feature of quantum fee
Theory you can't have any kind of
physics at any scale completely detached
from the rest of the world if you put
enough energy in or if you have enough
statistics you'll see these effects so
if we see an indirect effect of this
kind like a Decay that happens more
often or less often than the southern
model predicts that would not only tell
us there's something we are missing like
the stern Garden experiment right that's
something that what it is is not
perfectly clear but it also will tell us
at what energy scale this takes place
and these these implications are
incredibly important because they will
guide the next collider machine that it
will not be a hadron collided
necessarily that if we have these hints
we will build a machine that looks
specifically there what it is that we
see that TVs from the prediction
good
um so John
um uh John Beale Nielsen asked the
following question you mentioned the
measurement problem of quantum mechanics
what are your thoughts on that could new
physics come from understanding this
problem
they definitely could I mean there's
there's no um that that is the big
problem with um with you physics so it's
not a problem is this is the feature if
you will
um the the apart from certain guidelines
that we know need to be resolved right
so for example
um if you have a theory that is not
consistent then it can't be right so
you're missing something you have to go
after that right but if you have ticked
all these boxes like the standard model
if you include neutrino masses as well
is is the type is a kind of that theory
that apart from Gravity it really takes
all these boxes what guides us to
finding new physics is impossible to
predict if we knew it we would have
found already right
and um the the measurement problem is
one feature
um where I don't think there's anyone
who would claim that this has been
understood 100 yeah certainly um there
are certain questions I'm not a fan of
of theories replacing quantum mechanics
doesn't sound nothing I've seen sounds
really appealing to me to be honest I
think there are formulations of quantum
mechanics make sense they don't make
sense to us as macroscopic uh creatures
in a way but they make sense
intrinsically I don't think there's a
there's a contradiction and then one has
to be really careful when you when you
talk about the measurement problem I
think because the measurement problem
within quantum mechanics
um is a bit difficult I don't think this
is the right framework so um people
often say that you have like
um information exchanged or not really
information but you have a non-local
property that happens basically um that
doesn't doesn't follow the speed of
light which it should if it was in
agreement with a special theory of
relativity but quantum mechanics is not
a relativistic theory quantum mechanics
is um is a theory that completely
ignores special relativity so in
principle within quantum mechanics you
could have something that moves faster
than the speed of light is no
um velocity limit there right so really
framework to consider this question
would be Quantum field Theory which is
the only consistency of the combines a
Quantum framework with the special
theory of relativity and within Quantum
field Theory there are proven theorems
that you can't have you can't have any
interaction in space like distances or
these are distances that would need to
travel fast in the speed of light that
have any influence on each other so that
within the framework of qft is
completely consistent I don't see any
unsolved question there no great but I
don't want to I don't want people to
disengage from that because quite a few
theory is not the finance either it is
not in agreement with general relativity
so if you have a brilliant idea it might
well be that you find the next step
forward there
uh so our super producer of the into the
impossible podcast uh Mr Stuart volcow I
was just noting that Peter diamandis is
hosting a conference abundance 360 and
they're all talking about Ai and chat
GPT and how that's going to Revolution
as we already talked about that this is
just a chance for me to to broadcast the
fact that Peter's coming on the podcast
in a couple weeks and I'll be on his
podcast called uh moonshots and
Moonbeams or something like that uh a
very very uh interesting and Progressive
podcast that I am excited to be going on
so thank you Stuart uh memes of
Destruction
he uh another name I almost chose for
one of my kids uh Professor Einstein
once said I don't believe this is true
uh it sounds like something that Abraham
Lincoln said he said uh he claims that
Einstein said that if he had an hour to
solve a problem
I'd spend 55 minutes thinking about the
problem and five minutes thinking about
the solution I don't know if that's true
but uh Lincoln said something like if
you have an hour to cut down the tree
spend 55 minutes sharpening the ax but
I'm going to use memes of destructions
question as a way to ask about your
style how do you work what's it like to
be a graduate student in your group and
what kind of advice do you give to
graduate students on the practice the
craft of being a physicist as they are
apprenticing with you so what kind of
what's your style how do you work on
problems
um so personally I'm so it very much
depends on the problem I'm working on
there are some questions I'm working on
where I have a pretty good idea on what
steps we have to take to get to a
solution
um these are the problems that in the
end are probably the least interesting
problems because uh if I if I know how
to approach them it's rather
straightforward and it is a good way
um to solve problems of this kind if you
have for example a master student or
someone who has never done anything in
physics because you you can guide them
it but I always tell my PhD students and
it's basically an underlying truth of
research is that you don't know where
you end up when you start a PhD most
likely if you look back three four years
later you won't even recognize what you
initially set out to do that might be
less true in experimental physics
whereas your your with a clearer picture
what you want to build but in theory you
basically try to nail down a question
that you want to answer and then you get
to work
um and uh on your way to find an answer
to that question you often find that
there might be much more interesting
questions related to that so um I
recently um read and and uh posted the
article by Steve Weinberg who gave a
recommendation to graduate students
which I can just fully commit to I think
this is completely right you should
start doing research you should not
waste too much time learning the basics
at least if you are at a level where you
can start a PhD to start with the
project it's the best thing you can do
you will learn on the way and you also
said you should go where the masses are
so if you're if you're at that level you
should not waste your time with
something that is too easy if it's too
easy then it's not a it's not really a
problem worth your time you should you
should go where it's uh where there's a
difficult problem that many people don't
seem to understand and try with it and
try to make progress there
um and so so I think both these things
are right and I um and I communicate
them usually to my students as well yeah
very good yeah so I have that tweet here
from you in the name of the late great
Stephen Warren bird let me see if I can
get that on the screen
that and then we're going to finish up
yeah four golden lessons by the late
Stephen Weinberg short read for young
and old so follow please Martin on
Twitter at Martin M Bauer uh on Twitter
and you'll get this and many more viral
tweets he's got the knack for going
viral which is uh elusive to to uh many
of us mortal mere mortals
um so we're going to finish up
um I'll take one more question from the
audience here uh and then
um and then we'll move on to the
patented final four questions although
it's getting super late there very
appreciative we gotta wrap it up you've
got a young kid at home I don't want to
keep you too long
um so I want to just ask one more
question about the uh something that's
outside your field which is going to be
the topic of my conversation with uh Dr
Felix flicker uh who's coming on um
recording with him tomorrow so leave
your questions for Felix flicker on
Twitter or on YouTube uh if you're
interested in condensed matter he's got
some viral Royal Institution videos
about magnetic monopoles and he's the
first you know theoretical condensed
matter physicist that I've had on and he
and I will be talking about all sorts of
things including the recent claims of
high temperature superconductivity and
so forth um so you mentioned the
beginning of this conversation that it
was thought that this measurement by
Stern and gerlock would be impossible
that it wouldn't exist and and as you
know the name of this podcast is Into
The Impossible and I asked many people
in the last couple of years what they
thought was impossible and later turned
out to be possible and by the way that
comes from Sir Arthur C Clarke who said
that the only way of determining the
limits of the possible is to go beyond
those limits into the impossible so
that's the name of the podcast and it's
kind of My Credo here on the project is
there anything that you might have
thought would be impossible when you
started your your journey as a scientist
but with the benefit of hindsight being
2020 you now have seen to be possible is
there is there anything you thought
might not be uh it might not be true or
even possible to Grapple with that has
become maybe not if not routine some
part of what we teach to students or
otherwise inculcated in your value
system as a physicist
so one thing that has happened is the
discovery of gravitational waves
um I might not have thought that when I
started my PhD because I wasn't in the
field but if you go back in history and
look at what people thought in the 70s
80s 90s every single step along the way
of this kind of experiments it seemed
completely unrealistic to end up where
we are and that this is now basically
its own field of astronomy it's its own
like multi-messenger version of
astronomy besides neutrinos and photons
is absolutely incredible to me but let
me also mention two things that aren't
possible yet or that we don't have yet
but they are about to happen or they
might happen in the future and one of
them is the um
collider so we will have a potentially
immoral Collide in the US there is a
whole collaboration now building that
wants to work on this we want our
particles that actually decay in a
millionth of a second if they are
addressed they're really really
short-lived and to cool them then
accelerate them such that they are
long-lived enough with Einstein's time
dilation and then make them Collide to
do physics with them sounds absolutely
incredible if you think about it but
there has been some progress and there
needs to be more but eventually this
might happen it's uh it's really really
hard to believe but this might be
possible and another thing in another
field of physics is um is the
entanglement and the measurement of
macroscopic objects like the quantum
properties of macroscopic objects and
they're physicists that are working on
entangling things that are as big as as
a virus for example or things you can
even almost see with your with your Bri
this was completely Unthinkable
um for for decades and might even have
implications for quantum gravity so we
might learn for example whether the
gravitational for how it interacts with
the quantum properties of these objects
so this is um these two things are
absolutely incredible to me and I really
believe that they are about to happen
certainly within our lifetime but
probably earlier than that yeah so I
can't resist because the name of my
second book is Into The Impossible
um like the name of the podcast and
because the forward was written uh in
combination with my good friend James
alticher but also by Barry barish uh who
is the winner of the co-winner of the
2017 Nobel Prize and so Barry wrote the
forward and he also thought this was
impossible
um uh but uh but we went ahead and did
it they went ahead and did it and they
continued to do stuff like proposed to
build uh laser interferometers in space
so just it's amazing how something can
go from being you know purely even
discarded I mean Einstein didn't think
we never detect gravitational lensing
let alone gravitational waves he did a
little tiny calculation uh and he showed
it to be you know curiosity at best and
now we've detected it and it won a Nobel
Prize for for Barry and Ray Weiss who
have been guest and Kip Thorne who keeps
he doesn't keep rejecting me I I keep
writing him and he keeps saying he's too
busy but he never says go to hell so
Hope Springs Eternal that I'll get the
Mercurial Kip Thorne as well as the
remaining uh only remaining member of
the Troika uh last question Martin uh
that I asked my guest um Sir Arthur C
Clarke who also said you know the only
way of determining limits of the
possible is going to The Impossible he
also said when a elderly but
distinguished scientist
says that something is possible he is
almost certainly right but when he or
she says something is impossible they're
very likely to be wrong I'm not calling
you elderly but I'm calling you
distinguished I want to ask you in that
vein what have you changed your mind
about what have you been wrong about if
anything
what I've been wrong about
that's a good question because in my
feed of research I've been wrong a lot
so basically
um I would say
um almost so when you think about
physics beyond the standard model for
example right
um you're always working about you're
always working on problems that are
potentially discoverable you're not
necessarily set out some people do
obviously but do not necessarily set out
to um propose a new experiment that
might be built in 500 years that's not
really your goal you want to see what
can we do now what can we learn now and
there have been plenty of papers I've
written where I thought that maybe this
is around the corner we can check this
at the LHC and it's for adult but to be
right so um I I don't really that I
think one should distinguish between
proposals like this and actually I'm
happy to be wrong about those two and
what what scientists have as like their
fundamental belief this goes back to
what we talked about the stern Goddard
experiment as well so started the
experiment um believing that he would
not see what he saw then this one he
wouldn't have got the Nobel Prize for
that experiment then right so he was he
was completely convinced that he would
disprove that proposal what your
personal belief is in the in a in a
theory or in a proposal is is really
irrelevant
um to some degree it um it's much more
important whether it is scientifically
um solid um proposal that you put
forward you can work on it you can make
these proposals and you can be convinced
of them or not be convinced and can hope
they be right and not be right that has
no bearing at all of whether nature
follows uh your instincts and shows
whether they are true so we I'm happy to
have a podcast to talk about the things
that have been wrong it would be much
longer than this one
Professor Martin Bauer it's a delight to
finally get to talk to you I can't wait
to meet you in person in June when I'll
be in the UK I'll let uh the audience
members know about that people in the UK
who wanted meteorites for me for so long
I will bring a whole pocket full of
space Schmutz and I'll give a special
chunk to my friend Martin we meet in
person Martin thank you so much uh Team
uh into the impossible stick around the
rest of this year is shaping up to be
just phenomenal you're not going to
believe some of the guests who are
coming on and some of the opportunities
I'm going to have to go on other
people's podcasts so stay tuned for that
and it's really because of you guys the
the audience and the great guests that I
get like Martin
um and it's just uh it's really
overwhelming to have over the hundred
and two thousand people now uh following
us and uh and and participating because
I can't really do it without you guys so
when I post something on Twitter I post
something on YouTube please uh the best
thing you can do first of all give a
thumbs up if you like this interview
write a comment if you like this
interview the algorithm is still
governed by AI so that's one of the best
ways to engage engage with Martin engage
with all my guests ask them questions
and let them know what you thought of
their appearance and hopefully we'll use
that to get a even more guest of the
caliber that we had today I can't uh
thank Martin enough for his time and
wisdom
I look forward to many of these as I
said maybe I'll do one in person in the
UK that'd be super fun I will get you
out here in San Diego I'd love to host
you here and we have some rainy weather
lately so it'll make you feel at home
you will thank you very much Brian it
was it was already on congratulations to
the hundred thousand it's uh it's quite
an achievement I told you thank you so
much
yes yes me too and uh be well and thank
you so much and good night good night
and thank you so much Danke Schoen bye
Martin
see you soon bye